desde el perro boca abajo pasando por la
respiración pranayama hasta el sur yang
a mascar este martes se celebra el día
internacional del yoga y en todo el
mundo los practicantes se han reunido
para celebrarlo
el solo hecho de estar en la esterilla
ni siquiera en la esterilla el simple
hecho de respirar ese aire fresco ese
plano es una sensación tan increíble en
la ciudad patrimonial de emisora el
primer ministro indio se unió otras 15
mil personas en la postura del niño para
encabezar las celebraciones el tema de
este año es yoga para la humanidad y el
premier no ha ocultado su objetivo de
seguir popularizando esta práctica
millones de personas con paz interior
crearán un entorno de paz global
así es como el yoga puede conectar a la
gente así es como el yoga puede conectar
a los países
el día fue lanzado personalmente por
modi en la asamblea general de la onu en
su ascenso al poder en 2014 los expertos
dicen que su entusiasmo por su difusión
podría ser un ejemplo de poder blando
los orígenes indios e hindúes de la
práctica
[Música]
en nepal y blanca el centro y el sur de
asia se practica ampliamente en toda la
región y esos atributos interculturales
son promovidos con fuerza por el pj pe y
promueve que india tenga un papel
central en la región a nivel cultural y
a nivel mundial se considera un gran
éxito diplomático
se calcula que el movimiento y práctica
alrededor de esta antigua disciplina
física y espiritual tiene un valor de
unos 80 mil millones de dólares